comme toutes les histoires de chercheurs
d'or la nôtre commence sur un bateau ou
plutôt trois parmi les plus célèbres au
monde la pinta la ligne a et la santa
maria les caravelles de christophe
colomb de retour d'amérique après une
odyssée de plus de sept mois
ça devait être fou de voyager sur ces
bateaux s'en apercevoir une mouette ni
une côte juste l'horizon et se dire on
verra bien quand on arrivera
en mars 1493 colons revient en héros et
les cales chargé d'or à son port de
départ palos de la frontera au sud de
l'andalousie la ville conserve fièrement
les reproductions grandeur nature de ces
trois navires
au total il y avait 90 marins répartis
sur les trois bateaux
attention à la tête
il valait mieux pas être trop grand
figure toi que christophe colomb était
justement de petite taille ça c'est le
gouvernail c'est ce qui permettait de
diriger le bateau
est là il faut descendre comme si
c'était une échelle
nous suivons notre guide dans les
entrailles de la caravelle
là on reconnaît la forme de la poule c
la partie avant du bateau à l'abri du
vent et des vagues lakhal était à la
fois le dortoir et le garde manger de
l'équipage
hélas comme vous le voyez il ya aussi
beaucoup de tonneaux c'est là qu'il
stocker l'eau pour tout le voyage
sur ces navires d'un autre temps les
visiteurs se rêve matelots ou capitaine
il flotte ici comme une envie d'
aventure
j'imagine que ça devait dur mais aussi
fantastique de traverser des tempêtes en
plein atlantique sur ce qui ressemble à
une simple coque de noix
pour beaucoup de marins le voyage se
terminer à quelques pas de là derrière
cette porte
là franchir n'était pas vraiment bon
signe
ou est-ce qu'on est ici nous sommes dans
l'ancien hôpital de la miséricorde c'est
là qu'on essayait de soigner les marins
qui avaient attrapé en amérique des
maladies nouvelles alors inconnu des
européens comme la dengue ou la fièvre
jaune
quelques marches plus haut sylvia tient
à nous montrer le plus grand héritage de
ses premiers explorateurs
cette carte a été dessinée d'après les
observations et les mesures faites lors
des tous premiers voyages vers le
nouveau monde
mais le périple de colomb n'est pas tout
à fait terminé il lui faut encore rallié
séville pour livrer sa cargaison d'or
ramenées d'amérique et il doit
absolument le faire par bateau pour
comprendre pourquoi nous embarquons avec
mercedes une historienne de la région
tout le monde savait que l'on revenait
avec de l'or plein les cales emprunter
les autres c'était s'exposer à une
attaque de brigands c'était plus
dangereux que le fleuve beaucoup plus
dangereux et en plus le voyage était
bien plus long par la terre
mais naviguer sur ces eaux à
l'embouchure du fleuve guadalquivir
reste une mission périlleuse mario notre
capitaine du jour on sait quelque chose
regarder on aperçoit d'ici un ancien
cargo de marchandises qui devait
apporter du riz jusqu'à séville la
légende raconte que le capitaine était
disons un peu alcoolisé et qu'il a
échoué son d'atouts sur un banc de sable
on l'a laissé ici comme une mise en
garde pour les marins pour qu'ils se
souviennent que le guadalquivir est
encore plus traître que la mer il ne
faut surtout pas baisser la garde
surtout en allant par là
avec l'arrivée des conquistadors sonne
l'occar de barrameda passe d'un petit
port de pêcheurs à une riche cité
marchande c'est d'ailleurs derrière les
grilles de la demeure d'une des plus
influentes familles de la ville que nous
allons admirer un héritage méconnu des
explorateurs les plantes exotiques
pour leur élection les églises et les
familles nobles ont été les premières à
créer des jardins avec les plantes que
les explorateurs ramenait du
nouveau-monde domaine celle ci par
exemple elle est tout à fait commune en
europe maintenant mais elle vient
d'amérique latine
ont les étudiait pour essayer d'en faire
des médicaments
nous quittons la ville et ses jardins en
longeant le guadalquivir cap vers le
nord
[Musique]
nous entrons dans une vaste zone
marécageuse entièrement dédié à la
culture du riz la isla minima c'est ici
dans ces paysages gorgée d'eau et sous
un soleil accablant que nous rencontrons
tony et ses mille cinq cents brebis
fraîchement tondues
elles sont en pleine transhumance on
nous devons quitter ces étendues plates
pour aller au delà des montagnes
bientôt il faudra marché de nuit quand
les chaleurs seront trop forte on pourra
plus le faire deux jours ici en
andalousie de
notre route s'est faite chemin de
poussière les kilomètres défilent et
nous avons un problème il nous faut
passer sur l'autre rive mais aucun pont
à l'horizon seule solution monter à bord
de cette drôle d'embarcation
[Musique]
un jour combien ça coûte 3 euros 20
hockey 3 et 20 vous fait la traversée de
combien de fois par jour on les compte
même plus on n'arrête pas de 6 heures du
matin à 22 heures 30 plus de 150
véhicules traversent ainsi chaque jour
le fleuve et certains plus encombrant
que d'autres j'ai des champs de part et
d'autre du fleuve et sans ce bateau je
mettrais 2h30 pour aller d'un champ à
l'autre et avec le bateau
seulement 30 minutes
il n'y a aucun pont jusqu'à sévit pour
pouvoir laisser passer les bateaux donc
tant qu ils ne construisent pas un
tunnel sous le fleuve on peut gagner
notre pain comme ça
nous voilà donc du bon côté du fleuve
pour rejoindre notre prochaine étape
une ferme gigantesque et majestueuse
dans le plus pur style andalou niché sur
les bords du guadalquivir
[Musique]
pour moi c'est une passion depuis
toujours petit j'étais déjà au milieu
des choix je le serai jusqu à la fin
[Musique]
l'huile est de pure race andalouse le
sel du fleuve lui apporte beaucoup de
minéraux et ont fait un cheval robuste
un décor grandiose qui a attiré les
caméras de cinéma pour le tournage d'un
film bien connue des français
c'est ici qu'a été tourné une scène de
la folie des grandeurs avec louis de
funès la production n'avait pas de
budget pour louer la ferme alors ils ont
proposé de la repeindre intégralement
comme nous sommes très près de
l'embouchure du fleuve les embruns salés
attaquent en permanence les peintures
le guadalquivir tour à tour adversaires
et allié des andalous il est toujours
utilisé pour le transport de
marchandises et nous imaginons tout à
coup les caravelles qui naviguait
autrefois chargé d'or jusqu'à ces villes
comme elle nous remontons les 50
derniers kilomètres qui nous séparent de
la capitale andalouse pour terminer
notre voyage nous avons rendez vous sur
les quais à un endroit bien précis
nous sommes en face de la tour dorée
c'est ici qu'ils étaient stockés lors
rapporté par les explorateurs c'était le
point final d'absolument chaque bateau
qui revenait d'amérique imaginer
l'importance de cette tour c'était l'un
des bâtiments les plus surveillées du
pays
le butin devait encore faire une
dernière traversée plus d'océan ni de
fleuves venant juste de rues plus loin
son grand voyage s'achever là entre ces
murs où scintille encore un riche passé
voici la maison de la monnaie c'est ici
qu'ils étaient fondus l'or et l'argent
venu du nouveau monde pour fabriquer des
pièces de monnaie cet édifice
représentait le pouvoir de l'empiré
espagnol
aujourd'hui plus un lingot plus un écu
derrière ses arches mais séville brille
toujours d'un charme inexplicable lorsqu
au soleil couchant la ville semble se
parer d'or comme pour se souvenir du
temps où elle rayonnait dans toute
l'europe grâce aux trésors des
conquistadors